m
imagine que tu sois surpris au lit un
jour comme ça chez toi ou dans un hôtel
à l'improviste par le père du petit
maxime olivier invité surprise etc avec
avec quelqu'un d'autre
qu'est ce que c'est qu'il ferait le plus
au monde c'est d'être surpris avec deux
mecs ou avec une fille bien identifiés
rejoindre avant c est cool comme
j'espère qu'il serait c'est pas ça m'est
jamais arrivé même si ces deux mecs
c'est moi qui te rejoindre ou non ne
faites pas des plus si c'était de me
tiens oui enfin ça ne donnerait pas
beaucoup à part je suis prête à tout
c'est l'amour ^ ^ katla qui croit la
réincarnation terrain quand est ce que
tu vois ça est très fermé où frédéric
françois veillette et la ta maison de
disques il faut lui envoyer du personnel
et frédéric françois ou ans françois
valéry jaloux c'est terrible j'avoue
qu'il vaut mieux pas sans un carnet
je prendrai quand même françois valéry
moi personnellement fassent tuer c'est
vraiment non bon bah tu les connais pas
tout le monde j'ai cotisé déconner
restait peut-être pas particulièrement
tu les aimes pas pourquoi parce qu'ils
ne représentent pas vraiment le mal dans
toute sa splendeur
est-ce que tu serais prête à mourir
comme ça là maintenant sur le champ pour
que tous les enfants du monde soit l'or
pour qu'il pût d'apartheid en afrique du
sud leur abondance non je ne m'en fous
pas ému un affreux mourir morte c'était
un gars à quoi françois salessy suis
passé un deal comme ça avec le bon vieux
fumeur il ya plus l'apartheid je veux
pas mourir
je demanderai si le pas prendre ma
copine
à part ça c'est quand même pas des comme
ça quand elle n'était quand même pas
pour être un mot que j'ai monté là sur
le coup alors imagine maintenant que
c'est plus de pognon
car que d'un seul coup tu as puis tapez
une tu qu'elle lui remirent plus
d'argent terry qu'est-ce que tu ferais
bourré de l'argent est ce que je serai
prête à aller taper sur des vieux géant
leur faire le sac à la sortie de la
banque quand ils viennent de toucher
leurs votre aide
ou alors tout à fait dit je pense pas un
autre plutôt faire taper dessus
c'est un bon coeur oui tout on peut
trouver du bon on a un trou c'est sûr
que je sois je choisirais l'évier bon on
continue tu as toujours plus d'argent
1 est ce que tu serais prête être venir
c'est que la mère denis est mort deux
malheureuses c'est bien c'est bien
triste elle est mort est-ce que tu
serais prête à devenir la nouvelle maire
denis pour un million de dollars 1
million de dollars et fait subir un côté
beaucoup d'argent non non c'est pas
cette nuit la nouvelle mini la nouvelle
maire de nuit ni poser à fouesnant dans
mamie nova n'y a personne tu préfères tu
préfères être pauvre très pauvre tu ton
fils le pot maxime il aura pas de quoi
cesser les chaussures
non mais c'est un jeu imagine vous aider
vous aimez crise donc tu préfères que
ton enfant meurt de faim plutôt que
faire la publicité des machines à laver
la télévision chez ca m avoir de l'eau
nous donnerait le st jusqu'à 6 mai dans
le hall de la chambre